Hoy vamos a hablar de algo muy
importante: Cómo separar un país de otro...
porque mucha gente que se piensa que
esto del independentismo solamente
ocurre en Cataluña y en España pero
nada más lejos de la realidad. En el
mundo hay cientos de casos de
regiones que se quieren separar del
país al que pertenecen. En Europa
podemos contar decenas de ellos. En el video de hoy
vamos a hablar de los principales. Vamos
con ellos
Bienvenidos a VisualPolitik, soy Enrique Fonseca esto que ves en la foto se llama
PORTAS BOHEMICA
Está entre República Checa y Alemania pero esto no siempre ha sido así. Antes formaba
parte de otro país que ahora mismo ni
siquiera existe. Un país que se llamaba
el Imperio Austrohúngaro. Después de
la I Guerra Mundial pasó a formar
parte de otro país que tampoco existe
en nuestros días que se llamaba
Checoslovaquia. Luego llegó Hitler en la
II Guerra Mundial y lo invadio. Dijo
que eso era ahora Alemania y durante unos años fue parte
de Alemania. Luego cuando Hitler
perdido la guerra, volvió otra vez a
formar parte de Checoslovaquia y hoy en
día es parte de lo que conocemos como
República Checa. En Europa, solo en Europa se han cambiado las fronteras, los países
se han creado países a partir de otros, otros se han juntado... y hoy vamos a
hablar de los principales movimientos
secesionistas, es decir regiones pequeñas
que se quieran separar del país al que
pertenecen. Sól vamos a hablar de los principales
porque sería imposible hablar de todos
ellos. Porque hay cientos.
Países pequeñitos o regiones que
se quieren separar. Solamente para que
os hagáis una idea... solamente en Italia
hay tres regiones distintas cada una con
su referendum de independencia
convocado por internet con su partido político
nacionalista y con con sus discursos y
sus legitimaciones. En Ucranía tenemos
algo parecido: está por un lado la
invasión rusa, la tensión separatista
por parte de
de algunos de los que viven en Donesk, desde la población rusoparlante que quedan en
el este de Ucrania... hay muchísimos
ejemplos y no podríamos dedicarnos a
todos así que sólo vamos a hablar de los más
importantes
os dejo con Alberto que nos va hablar de
Escocia.
Escocia que no podía faltar en nuestra
lista. A menudo confundimos Reino Unido con
Inglaterra. En realidad Inglaterra es sólo una región de Gran Bretaña
Hay otras más también está Gales,
Irlanda del Norte, Escocia...
Los escoceses siempre han tenido
bastante autonomía
de hecho tienen su propio sistema legal
y jurídico que tiene muy poco que ver
con el derecho de gentes. Desde la época
de William Wallace, las relaciones entre
Inglaterra y Escocia no han sido muy
buenas y no sólo en la política tienen sus
diferencias
los escoceses votan más a partidos de izquierdas mientras que en
Londres son más conservadores.
Por si fuera poco Escocia es una de las
zonas más ricas del Reino Unido y es
que buena parte de esa riqueza viene por
el petróleo que hay en su territorio
marítimo. Las foto que véis es de ABERDEEN
ahí están todas las empresas
petroleras que explotan en el famoso
petróleo del mar del norte como os podeis
imaginar, los escoceses son de todo menos pobres.
Y aún piensan que podrían
ser aún más ricos que compartir los
beneficios del oro negro con sus vecinos
ingleses. La historia ya la conocéis: en
2014 se convoca un referéndum de
autodeterminación y ganaron los que
querían seguir unidos.
Sin embargo el Partido Nacionalista
Escocés continúa subiendo en
popularidad y su líder Alex Salmón
parece dispuesto a hacer otro referendum
Bueno, Enrique, y de Escocia... ¿A dónde nos llevas?
Pues si te parece, Alberto, del castillo de William Wallace
nos vamos a ir a castillo del Conde Drácula
como sabes es Transilvania, que es una
región que forma parte ahora mismo de
Rumanía
sin embargo en la época del auténtico
Conde Drácula era una región
autónoma de lo que se conocía como al
imperio Húngaro.
De hecho del auténtico, el original, Vlad
Tepes, Vlad "el empalador", no hablaba
rumano sino que más bien habló húngaro. En esta región que ya os digo
tenía cierta autonomía dentro del
imperio húngaro vivían por un lado los
campesinos y la gente pobre, que hablaba
rumano, y luego la nobleza y la alta
sociedad que hablaba húngaro y eran los
que se les conocía como los SZEKELYS que
les de hecho por eso esa zona se la
conoce como SZEKELYLAND
La nobleza húngara no es que fuera...
tolerante, no es que fuera muy pacífica,
de hecho a tí, Alberto, que te gustan las
historias un poquito truculentas
te recomiendo que te leas algo sobre
Erzebeth Bathory. que era una condesa
húngara que llevó a bañarse en la
sangre de sus súbditas.
Así se las gastaban los nobles
húngaros. Volviendo a lo que nos
ocupa, después de la II Guerra
Mundial con la dictadura de Ceaucescu
deciden qué Transilvania pase a formar parte ahora de del nuevo estado
rumano
los rumano-parlantes que vivian en esa zona
deciden entre comillas vengarse y acabar
con todo vestigio de cultura húngara de
entonces prohiben en el idioma, prohíben las tradiciones, prohíben
la cultura... todo lo que lo que queráis y
hacen además una operación de
reubicación de población cogiendo a
todos los criminales, ladrones, gente de
baja estofa que había en el resto de
Rumanía y colocándoles en Transilvania
para verse así poco a poco van
disolviendo y desapareciendo destruyendo
lo que podía quedar de de cultura
húngara. Después del comunismo, los
húngaros que han quedado, que todavía
son una parte importante de la
población...
los húngaros que quedan ahora, pues lógicamente odian a
los rumanos y quieren separarse de ellos.
Entonces han hecho todo tipo de
manifestaciones, de referéndums, de
movimientos políticas de todo tipo para
conseguir convertirse en un estado libre
asociado de Rumanía es decir compartir
si hace falta política exterior y
ejército pero para todo lo demás ser
un estado totalmente independiente. Hay que hay que resaltar que
Transilvania es la zona más más rica
de
Hungría... perdón, de Rumania.
Es donde hay más industrias una de las
zonas pues más más prósperas de la
zona y eso pues hace que también pues
quedan quieran independizarse para
para poder disfrutar de su riqueza sin
tenerla que compartir con el resto del
país. Además tiene en
características especiales: es el único
movimiento nacionalista, el único
movimiento secesionista que en Europa están
apoyados por otro estado europeo. Es
decir, los que ellis que se quieren
separar de Rumanía cuentan con el apoyo
del estado del gobierno Húngaro. Apoyo
oficial: les mandan dinero, públicamente
le se les han apoyado ante todas las
instancias internacionales, de hecho en
2014 sacaron una propuesta de estado
libre asociado que lógicamente, el
gobierno rumano ni siquiera escuchó ni
siquiera se leyó,  pero que tuvo todo el
apoyo del gobierno Húngaro y fíjate
que los dos países, tanto Rumanía como
Hungría forman parte del la UE
Es un tema muy complejo y también
muy interesante que seguramente nos
dará pie para para otros vídeos. Buen
arranque pues apuntado queda ese
consejo literario. Pues de Drácula
nos vamos con los esquimales de
Groenlandia un país con el tamaño de
la Unión Europea y la población de Ávila.
Durante siglos Groenlandia ha sido una
Colonia de Dinamarca y durante siglos ha
mantenido sus tradiciones esquimales.
Es una zona prácticamente intacta hasta
nuestros días.
Hasta ahora el gobierno danés subvencionaba todo lo subvencionable. A cambio
tienen un montón de territorio para
establecer bases militares y alguna que
otra factoría para pescadores. Los INUIT, que es que es la forma respetuosa de
llamar a los esquimales, siempre han
querido ser
un estado independiente.
Este fervor soberanista se acentúa los
últimos años en los que se han descubierto
montones de yacimientos de petróleo, gas, piedras preciosas, uranio y otras mil cosas.
En otras palabras, los groenlandeses tienen una fortuna bajo sus pies y encima son
pocos para repartirlo. El Partido Nacionalista Groenlandés arrasa siempre
en las elecciones.
La última presidenta llegó a decir que
vivíría para ver su país completamente
independizado. Después tuvo que dejar
el cargo por un escándalo de
corrupción y ahora parece que el nuevo
gobierno tiene temas más urgentes que
la soberanía.
En cualquier caso, en unos días vamos a sacar un video hablando
específicamente de Groenlandia así que
vamos a dejar el tema para otra ocasión.
Y no podíamos hablar de independentismo
en Europa sin
en tal el caso de Bélgica. En Bélgica,
el independentismo es casi tan
tradicional como los gofres. Ha existido
desde que se creó el país hace cosa de
un siglo. Porque sí, Bélgica es un país
muy moderno. Y para que no lo sepa es un
país que está dividido en dos regiones. Dos zonas donde se hablan distintos
idiomas: en el Norte hablar una especie
de dialecto del holandés que se llama
el flamenco y tiene una cultura
protestante mientras que en el Sur es lo
que se conoce como la parte Valona
hablan francés y tienen cultura
católica. Esto lo que nos cuentan
siempre los medios de comunicación
siempre queda algún problema alguna
tensión nacionalista y  tienen
que hablar de Bélgica.
Sin embargo hay mucho más allá. Mirad
este mapa
En este mapa se pueden ver los
resultados de las últimas elecciones
regionales en Bélgica. Mirad una cosa:  la parte norte es casi en su
totalidad naranja, una naranja clarito
¿Verdad? Bien este color clarito
representa el partido Nueva Alianza
Flamenca que es un partido nacionalista
flamenco. O sea, que tiene separarse del
resto del país pero además es un
partido de derechas y republicano. Mientras que en el Sur es
mucho más heterogéneo, pero más o
menos se podría decir que la mayor
parte de las de las provincias o de de
los cantones votan al Partido Socialista
que es un partido de izquierdas si no es
explícitamente monárquico es un mucho
más amable con la monarquía de lo que
puede ser él el partido flamenco.
También hay
unas diferencias
políticas importantes luego estamos con
la economía
el Norte es muchísimo más rica que en el Sur. Tienen la mitad de paro, el doble de
renta per cápita y casi toda la industria.
Son gente mucho más rica y tienen
tienen la sensación de que con su
dinero se está subvencionando la vida a
los francoparlantes del Sur. En cierta
medida tenemos que darles la razón.
Para que os hagáis una idea, en el Norte se hizo un estudio y se contaron que
había más de 1.000 radares de control
de velocidad. De estos radares que te
sacan la foto la matrícula si te
pasas de del límite de velocidad.
Tenían como unos 1000. En la parte
francesa no llegaban los 50.
Así que imaginaros la diferencia. Los flamencos pagan
muchísimas más multas de velocidad que
los franceses.
Esto se puede aplicar a todo: impuestos,
multas, etcétera... con lo cual muchas
veces los flamencos tienen esa sensación de decir "jolines es que estamos pagando la vida"
"esto no tienen ningún sentido"
Por si esto fuera poco, encima hay otro tema que no
se suele contar, que es la monarquía.
Bélgica es una monarquía pero, a
diferencia de la monarquía española, el
rey en Bélgica sí que tiene poderes
para intervenir en la vida
política. Es decir, en España ya sabéis
que el  rey
es un cargo meramente institucional: no puede decir "esta ley se
pasa, está no". En Bélgica sí. Es decir, en
Bélgica el parlamento aprueba una ley
pero luego el rey puede vetarla y puede
decir no esto no es tan malo no lo
apruebo. Y de hecho ha pasado: ya no es
que es una cuestión
meramente tradicional: no.
Por ejemplo en el caso de
la ley del aborto.
El parlamento belga votó a favor de
legalizar el aborto, vamos a decir, y el
rey lo vetó y echó para atrás todo el
proyecto de ley. Y hubo que volver a
votarlo, hubo que cambiar la ley, etc... o sea que es una cuestión
muchísimo más compleja de lo que
parece.
Ortega Gasset decía que las naciones se crean o bien juntando
países que ya existían, o bien separándolos. El separatismo ni es nuevo ni
eso ni es único de Cataluña.Tampoco se
puede decir que sea más o menos
legítimo que el unionismo. Supongo
que hay que analizar caso por caso. Lo
que sí está claro es que antes de
opinar hay que conocer las razones de
unos y de otros y tratar de dialogar.
No obstante si no estás de acuerdo,
siempre puedes aportar tu opinión
en los comentarios de este vídeo.